hi guys sci-fi recapped here today I am
going to explain the film called wife
like spoilers ahead watch out and stay
safe lifelike Enterprises is a
futuristic tech company that specializes
in producing AI robots recently they
have successfully developed AI
companions which are beautiful female
robots designed to serve the owners the
CEO of the company Mary inventor asserts
that these companions can even pleasure
the owners as per their demands in the
following scene William Bradwell a top
agent who is assigned to look after the
welfare of these wife material robots
visits the company and meets with a
hologram image of Marion a latter
immediately expresses his condolences
for William's late wife Meredith and
reveals that he has prepared an AI bot
just like her he put all of Meredith's
memories and habits to prepare the bot
later William sees his newly programmed
AI wife for the first time and gets
taken aback nonetheless he quietly takes
her home hoping that they can start a
new Journey from today at home looking
at the new Meredith William recalls
their first meeting when Meredith came
to his front door and requested him to
sign a petition to shut down y-flag
slowly the AI Meredith opens her eyes
and William teaches her the basics like
breathing walking and taking care of the
house as she begins to settle down at
home William inquires about her feelings
Meredith mentions that everything around
her appears to be familiar later at
night William activates the intimacy
mode in Meredith and enjoys Pleasant
intercourse after this when William asks
her to spend some more time with him
Meredith reminds him that she has to
recharge her battery in order to be
fully functional the next day she then
walks out of the room and approaches her
charger surprisingly when she pulls out
a nearby drawer she discovers the real
Meredith's journal and a small brush to
comb her hair soon she shuts the buck
and begins her charging operation the
next morning Meredith prepares breakfast
for William and inquires about his job
the latter reveals that he works for the
companion Recovery Unit in which he
protects and looks after ai-powered
female robots like her at the same time
in the new news it is mentioned that
this week alone 15 companion abductions
have been recorded and the number is
increasing every week William reveals
that the abduction is being carried out
by a group called scair which has been
forcing the companions to go into crowds
with bonds attached to their chests soon
William leaves for work and after he is
gone Meredith enters the makeup room and
starts trying them one by one she wants
to quickly learn the activities of real
Meredith and give William absolute
pleasure on the other hand William
arrives at work and attends a briefing
regarding some missing wife-like robots
here we get to know that William is the
most effective agent in retrieving the
robots from the control of the sca IR
group Williams supervisor reminds them
to stay attentive especially with the
sca ir's Rising membership soon after
the Protection Agency locates some of
the kidnapped robots who are being held
in a house in a dark room Wendy one of
the wife-like robots eventually opens
her eyes and after assessing her
situation she silently departs the room
attempting not to alarm their abductors
after noticing no one around she gets a
coat and flees via the window William
notices her but is advised to wait for
assistance from his colleague Jack but
sadly he disobeys and rushes to grab the
girl before she flees as he gets closer
he discovers she's wearing a shock
collar around her neck William takes it
away before asking her how many people
are in the house the girl replies that
she does not know the exact number
following this William enters the house
and finds a programmer of the sca IR
group practicing virtual boxing William
knocks the boy down and moves forward
inside he notices another wife-like
robot ready to get reprogrammed and
freed he immediately approaches the
robot and removes the collar from her
neck right then another guy arrives
there pointing a gun at the third
wife-like robot William tries his best
to bargain with the guy and stop him
from harming the robot unfortunately
when the guy shows no sign of resistance
William has no choice so he shoots him
dead the scene then shifts to Meredith
who is charging herself at home while
lying at her charging bad her dream
program activates and she meets her
Dreamscape operator Ido who gives her
the dream of a birthday celebration she
is escorted to visit a masked guy in the
dream who hands her a card with a
picture of a red bird on it he assures
her that it will Aid her recall her past
before Meredith can ask anything the
masked man walks away next William
returns to wife like HQ with the three
recovered companions there he sees two
other companions who disrespect him and
show him their middle finger he is told
that they frequently fail resist their
owner and must be repaired a few times
every month meanwhile Meredith inquires
with Ido about the masked man who handed
her the bird and printed business card
Ido tries his best but can't discover
any evidence of such an encounter
following this she inquires about real
Meredith's interests expressing a desire
to learn to knit seeing her urge to knit
Ido installs a knitting program for her
later Meredith knits the bird picture
from the card onto a pillow she then
gets on her bicycle and goes for a spin
outside she nearly collides with a woman
called Louis and falls off her bike
Louise tells her that she did it on
purpose and that she is here to tell AI
Meredith that they are running out of
time after saying this Louise just walks
away from there leaving Meredith
confused later in the evening as William
is giving a bath to Meredith she tells
him about her encounter with Louise
after hearing her out he reveals that
women don't like the wife-like
companions so Louise must be probably
envious of her sometime later Meredith
gives William the pillow she knitted
earlier at first he is startled since he
had no idea she could knit but when she
looks at him with loving eyes he
unwillingly tells her that he likes the
design William then begins telling her
that the first time he met her was on a
park bench where she was reading a book
he claims that she first refused to sit
close to him but later agreed at night
Meredith is reading the diary when she
summons Ido to activate her Dreamscape
she then requests him to feed her the
memory when she was reading a book in
the park Ida reveals that some of the
memories that she mentioned are not
available so he chooses one at random
surprisingly the same park scene in
place and his Meredith looks up she
notices the masked guy in her dream and
not William seeing the masked man
Meredith gets shocked and inquires as to
why he is following her the man
approaches her snatches her hand and
orders her to remember right then
William gently shakes her awake assuring
her that she is fine she inquires about
the identity of the masked guy but
William informs her that it was all a
horrible dream after Meredith goes to
the bedroom William quietly comes out of
the house and dumps the cushion that
Meredith gave him earlier in the garbage
bin before sleeping Meredith reads the
journal and also watches some videos of
real Meredith spending time in a tent
with the love of her life the following
day William goes to rescue another
wife-like companion who has started
working in an office when William urges
her to get back to the wife like HQ she
replies that she will end her life
instead of going back to the HQ as
William starts forcing her to join him
she runs to the nearby window and jumps
ending her life in the next scene
Meredith returns home to see Louise
sitting on their couch Luis tells her
that she must gather herself and also
informs her that the guy with the mask
wishes to meet her she also tells
Meredith that his name is Keen and that
they have a past narrative does not show
any interest in meeting King and says
that the conversation is being recorded
for William however Louise is unfazed
and she sends a threatening message to
William after completing work at the
office William returns home and is
surprised to see a new bird cushion that
Meredith knitted thinking that the
previous one got lost she also informs
William about Louise's visit as soon as
he hears this he immediately contacts
Jack and asks for his help to search for
Keen they decide to use Meredith and
lurkin to them sometime later Jack
arrives there and sets up his sleep
tracking equipment he then requests
Meredith to visualize everything is real
in Her Dream following this Meredith
sleeps and meets with Ida who chooses a
Halloween location and takes her to an
abandoned house Meredith wearing a
skeleton costume enters the building and
meets Keen here Keane Reveals His Face
for the first time and tells her that
though his memories are white from her
storage he will not stop looking for her
before leaving he also gives her a
location to memorize and meet him in the
real world to his bad luck William and
Jack also get to know about the location
and they immediately head there with
their team however William only manages
to find a masked mannequin in the
location and returns home empty-handed
at Home Meredith again asks William
about Keane and he lies to her telling
her that Keen is a bad guy and he erased
all of his memories to help Meredith
live a happy life William then contacts
Jack and requests him to set them up
again for Dreamscape so that he can
confront Keane at first Jack denies him
and informs him that trying to do that
again can block the Dreamscape and that
William may get stuck there forever but
later however when William forces him he
agrees in the next scene William and
Meredith are at Jack's house where he
sets William to enter Meredith's dream
and meet Keane Williams suggests
Meredith wake up when her battery
reaches 10 to which she agrees soon
Meredith enters her dream mode and wakes
up inside a forest Keenan William also
arrived there and before confronting
Keane William asks Meredith to run away
so that he can talk to Keen in private
as soon as Meredith runs away William
approaches Keane and starts beating him
up badly the Dreamscape shifts to a
birthday celebration setting and William
and Keane enter the party while still
fighting as William fights on he orders
Meredith to escape again but she doesn't
go far enough and here's William Warren
Keen that he will erase her memory
William almost murders Keen but before
he can do so Meredith's battery dies and
comes below 10 percent she then suddenly
wakes up compelling William to come out
of her dream as he wakes up he gets
enraged stating that he was so close to
eliminating Keane William informs
Meredith that he will delete her
memories but she opposes this however
William somehow convinces her and she is
brought to wife like HQ and placed in a
room with other wife-like companions at
wife like HQ Meredith is welcomed by
other AI programmed robots as they have
all met previously one of the wife-like
robots Ali reveals to Meredith that they
have learned and how to preserve
memories and communicate information to
one another which will Aid the
ringmaster the head of the sca IR group
in bringing wife like down Ali and her
friend Liddy clarify that the ringmaster
is not an assailant but rather assists
them in living to programmed independent
lives Ali describes how she can conceal
her memories and her dreams Meredith
also follows her instructions and
successfully orders Ido to store her
precious memories in a random place from
where it cannot be wiped Meredith is
then transferred to a facility where her
memories are wiped meanwhile Louise
visits Jack's girlfriend and offers her
a USB desk for Jack narrative awakens
from her sleep but she has kept her
memories however she acts like she is
completely new and pretends to remember
nothing when she gets home she acts the
same way she always did before but at
the same time Jack walks in he confronts
William and claims that Meredith was
never his wife he reveals that William
murdered Keenan that he now only exists
in Meredith's Recollections which is why
they can't find him after are telling
him everything Jack tries to arrest him
but William shoots him and kills him on
the spot Meredith also sees this and
says that William murdered Jack exactly
like he did Keen she then reveals that
she knows everything and hasn't been
reset entirely the scene then shifts to
the time when Meredith meets William for
the first time at his house she asks him
to sign the petition against wife like
here William gets attracted to her and
starts stalking her later he forcefully
captures her and Keen before shooting
keen and taking Meredith home she begs
him to let her leave but he refuses
following this William tries his best to
take control of Meredith and make her
his own but to his dismay Meredith never
complies with him enraged one night when
she is asleep William grabs a pillow
with a red bird knitted on it and
suffocates her to death he then puts a
ring on her finger to make her seem like
his wife back to the present when
William gets to know that Meredith knows
everything he apologizes to her and
tries to justify his actions however
Meredith is in no mood to listen to him
and she sets settings to full strength
mode she then attacks William and
pinches his arm as she recalls her first
meeting with Keen on the Park Bench she
suffocates William with her crocheted
bird pillow and before walking out of
there places the engagement ring on the
cushion in the last scene Meredith
awakens in a different place and
declares that she is now free other
wife-like companions greet her return
and we discover that she is in fact the
ringmaster of the scai our group she
addresses the other to programmed robots
and promises that their memories will
never be erased again and that they will
never be another's control she closes
Her speech by saying life begins now on
the other hand at wife-like Marion
announces that one of their top agents
Jack has been killed by the sca IR group
and Promises to track down the
ringmaster and bring them to justice he
then assigns the task to agent William
Bradwell the movie ends with William
accepting the task and revealing to us
that he is actually an AI programmed
male robot
thanks for watching subscribe and hit
that like button to help our Channel
grow turn on the notifications so you
won't miss any of our new videos